[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bongo nicolas et
pimprenelle et et trois petits neveux
ont l'air très sage ce soir ils ne font
pas de bruit
j'étudie patron ils sont à l'école a
descend vite les voir nounours je m'en
veut surveiller cette clan ce sont les
seuls bonsoir les petits bouts ça ne me
fait pas de bruit
on étudie on est à l'école
oh c'est bien ça
mes petits neveux ou sorties ils sont
punis ils ont très mal travaillé ils ne
savent même pas faire des bateaux les
pauvres chéris ce normal ce sont encore
de bp tout faux faux alors montrez vous
petit âne
tu vois mon comme il travaille mal on
leur a mis des bonnets d'âne
mais s'ils travaillent mieux ils peuvent
les enlever mes petits neveux
je compte sur vous au travail
il est pendant ce temps là nous on
chante comme aller à l'école
pas besoin d'être grand juste quatre ou
cinq ans
il suffit tout simplement de se conduire
châtiment global lincoln au sol soucieux
bon et tout ce qu'il m'a pété récent car
tout le monde est content on venait
quant à lui quand on s amuse et la jolie
l'école à la grande maison il m'a des
crayons oui au fait du bateau où l'on
chantait des chansons à la chantilly
cognac deux filles et d'un garçon
on y apprend qu'ils le sont on joue avec
des pales ont toléré création musicale
et je ne peux pas nier parce que c'est à
l'école
cancale et des salons des gros des
petits et qui professait un mot si on
ira tous à vous y en a qui veulent
l'école usait mozilla les collines est
calculé rivet pour décimer tombe n'est
pas gagné vous avez très bien travaillé
bravo rémy toutou le faut ils trouvent
ça beau toit
il faut des progrès nicolas bon vous
pouvez enlever vos bonnets d'âne allons
au dos dans les écoliers quand on va à
l'école elle couche tout seul la nuit de
noces bonne nuit de noce produits
les écoliers attention en avant marche
[Musique]
bonne nuit les enfants
faites vite votre toilette embrasse bien
fort vous parents et aller vite au dodo
car pour aller à l'école il faut se
coucher tôt fait de beaux rêves pour
deux
[Musique]